and we're off
finale time
finale time
clitty jebez what is up you are first
hello dane you were close but i see you
a native potatoes hello mason
damiano
advert viron blizz grease hole oh
they're starting to move too fast
what is up everybody
finale time
let's do it yo hunter what up
wincheski
thomas swan doll
row heat mr fire pants fried chicken all
right i can't really it's it's going too
fast for now
listen slow it down jd i'll throw it up
here every week
it's objects up clancy i see it you did
made it why can't i slow this chat down
i'm trying guys hold on okay okay okay
hello hello everybody hello hello
hello hello
it's so good to see everybody
i'm very tired because i just got home
from today from l.a and i know
everyone's going to ask me what about
multiverse madness uh
it's a good movie um
i'm always like so cautious just to like
rate a movie before it comes out because
i don't want y'all to go in with
expectations
um
of it supposed to being a good movie or
like maybe hearing that it's been bad
because i don't want that to sway your
own opinion while you're watching it i
could just say i very very much enjoyed
it i think it's a great movie um
it's not exactly what i was expecting
but that is kind of like a good thing
um
i'm not gonna spoil anything just so you
guys know there's gonna be no spoilers
for multiverse of madness here so don't
worry about that um
my podcast comes out
thursday
and that's gonna be a spoiler review so
once you watch it thursday you can go
watch podcast
[Laughter]
let's make sure everything's all right
here let's make sure
everything's looking good on the phone
i don't uh
[Music]
oh because i'm not i'm logged into the
wrong youtube account that's why i was
like i don't see my notification go out
let's take a look-see
make sure everything is
sounding good
um see jenkins thanks for that super
chat
that's uh oh they changed uh
they changed how youtube kind of does
this stuff
um they're
they're very different movies um
they have like hold on let me
yeah okay you guys clearly okay we're
good they have very different vibes like
like really like they have very
different vibes and i think there's
there's gonna be a lot of people
who watch doctor strange multiverse of
madness and go wow
this was fantastic
and then and they'll say they'll
probably say like that this was better
than no way home because it's more their
style because it is like a darker
creepier
jump scare
that horror sam raimi type of movie um
so it has a little bit of a darker tone
so it's really hard to compare to no way
home even though yeah norway home does
have some dark moments but you know when
it's like peter parker spider-man
teenage kid dealing with you know
getting into college and his friends and
and then you know the three spider-men
are just together and you're like this
is so awesome
uh
they're very different tones so
uh
yeah
you know it's really hard because it's
like the three peter parkers is like the
three generations like that's it's so
it's so hard to compare um and i and
they're definitely both right there with
each other i don't know if i can say
what's better um
but yeah yeah jeff aquino thank you for
another super chat you're always coming
up with those really really appreciate
it yeah great week today or today great
week this week
good day today because it's vanilla
jonathan cahoon what is up a member in
the chat thank you for being here
bradley jones i see you what is going on
smart way sean bell tom
just swinder all right chad's moving
really fast again ah
okay hold on
i know i missed the super chat
azaya
dodgion
midnight sun's cameo in the post credits
oh dude wouldn't that be cool yeah man i
uh
i will say this
uh
don't
i don't i'm not gonna spoil anything but
the post credits for
multiverse of madness aren't
ridiculously big they're not like game
changers
on a giant scale
uh i mean maybe but they're not gonna be
like they actually weren't anything i
was expecting so uh
i don't know what you've heard besides
what you've heard from me so
[Laughter]
i can't be like it's what you said it's
not what you expect um
i enjoyed them uh
i i really i
i really
i'm not a horror fan but i really like
the movie
um just i mean
just the illuminati scene alone
and because we all know the illuminati
you're going to be in it because they're
literally saying the name illuminati in
the trailer
uh yes jonathan cahoon there are two
post credit scenes
um
yeah there are two post credit scenes
and i can see some people
in the chat kind of uh
kind of
figured out one of them um because one
of them's like
i'm not gonna say i'm not gonna say i'm
not gonna say you guys let me know i'll
do a video
uh
i'm gonna do a video on it and you guys
can comment and let me know
and then we'll do a live stream
next week maybe this weekend and we'll
talk about uh
we'll just talk about multiverse of
madness after everyone's had a chance to
see it so
yeah that'd be really cool
um yeah isaiah yeah no i know uh i i
think it would be cool if uh it led into
like the midnight suns and the post
credit for the finale tonight because
you have to wonder
because yeah like the producers and
oscar isaac they're all like yeah this
is like our one-off marvel piece
that didn't really have to connect it's
like okay but yeah you could say that
all you want but
at the end you could be lying because
that's just what kind of everybody has
to do at marvel right they can't just
straight up say you know what the plan
is like oh yeah no it totally connects
and then at the end there's a post
credit scene
it doesn't really work like that so
um
does wanda break the fourth wall in the
multiverse of madness uh i mean there's
the
trailer
where she stares at the camera
um
so if you count that
i'm just gonna be very vague with with
uh with everything
i'm just going to be super super vague
with uh everything i say
about multiverse menace there is a sorry
i am tired i did just fly in today not
too long ago from la so
um
i will say this there's a ton
of easter eggs in that movie really cool
easter eggs
uh
it's really cool and i was sitting next
to eric voss of new rockstars we were
talking and he had his notepad and he
was taking notes the whole entire time
super cool uh super cool guy we've met a
few times now so
great guy
so
no i
no the thor loving thunder trailer was
not one of the post-credits scenes i
will give you all that
there uh there was no trailers in the
post-credits scenes uh so so we'll see
uh thoughts on man thing being announced
in the mcu isaiah thanks for that super
chat um yeah i mean
i
think that marvel is kind of
especially with disney plus going down a
route of
maybe lesser known characters
so i think that's a totally viable
option i think a lot of people know who
man thing is but um
if you think about like the population
who's not like the super nerds like we
are and don't read comics and like don't
know all these lester characters um
i
lost my train of thought because i got
super chat sorry uh i i think it would
be fine
for a man thing to come in if they did
the right way like i would totally
welcome that um i think it would be
super cool um and you know there's you
know connections you could throw in
there with uh
sword right
uh
and uh
what the heck is the the the dinosaur
place
savage lance
you know those connections with man
thing like you could throw those like
it'd be cool like i think it would be
i'd be really cool thank you for
subscribing sue how's it going
yeah lizzy lizzy really did nail i will
say
uh
elizabeth olsen is the scarlet witch
like
she is wanda uh
i mean wow uh
i yeah she's
she is that character she just
absolutely
crushed it
uh retro entertainment yes i do about
multiverse madness there's gonna be a
lot to talk about yeah um
yes and i'm gonna have to figure out a
way to like you know
get a copy of it before it uh comes out
because i uh i don't wanna wait till it
comes out to do this breakdown because
uh no there is there's like i said
there's there's a lot of easter eggs and
um
just a lot of cool things
referenced um
i'm just so curious
as to what everyone's gonna think
about us about certain scenes in the
movie uh yeah there are two post-credits
scenes please don't spam
ismail what's up thanks for another
super chat always coming in with them
for tonight i hope they're able to
finish moon night without making it too
crowded also hope clia shows up in
doctor strange too uh i'm not giving any
spoilers away for dr strange too so i
won't even
comment on that uh but
i'm with you in the crowded part
especially since i've heard
you know it's supposed to be
like 42 minutes right like that was like
their latest rumor going around sean
cole batcher thanks so much for that
super chat appreciate it oh you know
what let me just pull up the super chat
page because sometimes they don't show
me
super chats that are like under
two bucks or something like that which
is really weird uh how do i find this
i've streamed before i know what to do
super chat super super there we go here
we go
it says something called super thanks
are now available
i don't even know what those are do you
guys know what those are
okay so sean gotcha retro gotcha sue
isaiah got you jeff see yeah i think i
think i
think i got everybody cool cool cool and
there's some coming in
[Music]
got a member in the chat brokers
thompson what's going on
do you think long is making a midnight
son uh that would be really cool that
would be really really cool i won't do
any spoilers uh
but i do think they'd be cool christian
robledo what is going on thank you for
that super chat very generous view any
thoughts on when max dillon elektro said
there's got to be a black spider-man
somewhere out there something along
those lines when he was in doctor
strange's trap of the sanctum do you
think that was hinting at miles yes 100
percent um
miles is coming
it's just a matter of when at this point
um
and i would like to see
tom holland spider-man set him up like
start to mentor him in the upcoming
spider-man films and then when tom
holland exits we get miles as the main
spider-man
that's what i really love to see but
yeah no it was totally
totally hinting at miles yeah yeah yeah
i also love that andrew like apologizes
for not for not being a black spider
he's like oh man i'm sorry
i love it okay wait hold on
i missed the super chat i know i did
uh billy book news i see your comment um
so here here's a hot topic about um
doctor strange
too people are saying like i'm not going
to take my kids to see it uh i
i
i'm not a parent i have nephews and
stuff and i would say
there there probably are some parts if
your kids are a little skittish and a
little young
um
that might haunt them
it's you know it's a pg-13 movie still
though right um
and i'm a baby when it comes to stuff
like just truthfully i i don't do horror
i i don't do that
genre very well i have nightmares and i
get up at night and i think you know
there's crap around me so it's just like
i might be the wrong person to ask that
but there definitely are some horror
creepy vibes to this film um and there
are deaths
you know
so
skinny fart nice how would you rate the
new doctor strange one out of ten thank
you for that um
super chat um
i've kind of been avoiding like ranking
it i really want to see it again um if i
had to i'm gonna give it a tentative
number and that's an eight
i i gotta see it again though i feel
like it's like it's a lot like there's
there's some parts that make you go like
this is the greatest movie right but uh
i said in my review i feel like it
should have been longer
um
there's so much i love like everything i
saw i loved like everything i watched i
loved
i
like you know i'm not gonna be picky and
just
pick things apart
uh that's not how i like to do things um
i just
i loved everything i saw and you know
i just wish it was longer
because i think it could have added a
lot of more like sentimental
scenes
so what a britwick another member yeah
so that's kind of the uh
uh that's kind of the only thing
shadowcatcher oh no that's a shame man
i'm really sorry to hear that your
theater shut down because of covid
that's really
have did they shut down again or they
just they've been shut down the whole
time because that's uh most of them are
open now
uh jonathan cahoon i don't know about
him baca being the next black panther i
think it makes sense but you don't have
to see on that
i'm just trying to make sure i don't
miss any super chats here
nick sales production hey thanks so much
really appreciate that super chat david
cousins is multiverse amanda's
emotionally equal to the way home uh see
that's kind of what i'm talking about i
wish it slowed down a little bit more um
even though i did love the pacing of the
movie because it just like it goes it
goes goes it goes like it it's uh it's
pretty awesome how how fast-paced it is
and the action's really cool and like
man like oh i really did love the movie
um
but to me it felt like there could have
been a little bit more emotional
connection between some characters
and it's not that there's not any
emotional connection it's that it goes
so fast
um
that
it doesn't fully take you there with the
emotional connections that's what i'll
say um whereas like we're not
you know spoilers for no way home if you
haven't seen it yet we're not may dies
no at home i'm like no
like just no
whereas doctor strange the multiverse of
madness i could honestly say was
probably
the
coolest
marvel
i can't say that there's so many cool
marvel movies it's an insanely cool
movie like everything you see is like
like the final scene i'm just sitting
there like watching it happen i'm like
this is cool like this is freaking
awesome
like truly i i really really
really thought it was awesome
uh how was my experience with the shish
shijlani in noe home i just talked to
chief today he was asking me about the
multiverse of madness uh you know he sue
he was super kind super fun guy we were
live we sat right next to each other and
we were laughing and crying and high
fiving and you know my experiences with
him have been awesome so far so
damien warner thank you for that dinner
super chat do you think the mc will come
to an end near future is there enough
material from the comics to get to go
into our old and wrinkled
big glasses by the way wolf life thank
you so much these are my blue light
glasses
uh
they're provided by gamer advantage and
uh yeah they were a sponsor and i
usually only try to do sponsors that i
actually use
or thank are worth some type of value
so
appreciate that um
yeah sue right it's like such a cool
movie also did you message me on
instagram by the way i just don't know
if you're
a girl or a boy because i've i know some
koreans
uh
named sue as well in their name
uh i have a question for you
i don't think it's gonna come to an end
damien warner um
i can tell you by like the little things
i picked up in no way home that i think
other people will pick up as well i
think i see the direction that this is
going
and uh
yeah oh i gotta check if it's out it's
12.50 it's probably out on disney plus
let's get this finale going
yeah uh i will say don't go don't so i
went in expecting like a million cameos
don't don't expect a million cameos
that is all i will say um okay let's pop
in a new window here
wait no that's not what i want to do
gotta get this timer going on
this i'm gonna pop out into a window
this other one all right everybody we
are about to start the sixth episode and
we are gonna start this thing in five
four
three
two
one
and we're off
all right hold on
that's not it
let's get it real quick
underscore p.m because i'm never been
probably been watching for a little two
years one of the reasons i'm saying that
msu now grants all the growth and
success hey i super appreciate that
thank you so much for sticking with me
for so long i really appreciate it
uh sue can you put your
handle in the chat and then delete it
once i say i see it by any chance
because i didn't see any it also doesn't
show me all the tags from people too
it's really weird instagram is really
like
i i don't know it's really finicky with
what it shows you
all right so last episode we lost
stephen
and
oh what happened i passed it no
okay and yeah here we are
the music in this uh series has been
pretty dang great so far
all right i wonder what's uh
what's gonna happen here but we we're
going
your cat wants to watch episode two
hehehe i got another cat down here too
all right so here's stephen being shot
in the water is he coming back what's
happening they're just gonna bring him
back huh
oh
no i watched the whole dr strange
multiverse of madness i was asking
watch the whole thing
oh harold pulled him out
oh there it is
they have it
they have uh
ahmed's ashanti is that what that's what
it's called right
he just said oh
now what am i doing i need my moon night
drink hold on
i need my moon night drink i have it
right here
moon knight
it's actual moon knight g fuel
it's really cool this one has no
caffeine in it so
this episode is 40 minutes no it's 43 4
minutes
no pro yeah sue send an email to me
please thank you very much
it's so crazy how
i do need my field marcus i uh
oh snap that's really cool oh snap
oh leila what you gonna do you gonna
stop him
oh
you want something about knowing or
multiverse madness increase the hype the
illuminati scene is nuts
it's insane
like really it it it's amazing
ah mr anderson's here what up
oh look
how did
how did that get there i'm so confused
okay
very now i'm confused
uh-huh
oh
oh snap
that's a lot
oh
i was curious
anyone gonna survive okay okay okay we
in it we in it we in it
oh
[Music]
what you're gonna do you're gonna
do some stabbing
oh
oh
huh
punch you
is that really all it takes
no
no
listen to the oh my gosh gabriel's the
guy from fortnite oh my gosh i hate that
so much i mean not that you said it but
you know that whole thing
okay well that's clearly the pyramid
that they're gonna fight on that we've
seen
the final footage of
oh now you freaking realize it
these stupid idiots all you have to do
is investigate for like one second
what you got osiris
there he is
oh no
oh snap
oh snap
what if she just killed him
oh
oh
who
tell me who
oh
all right
so
go get layla
dragon immune that moon knight
sparkling water
from g fuel
oh snap
oof
all right all right what's going on
what's going on
where's steven with the v
well it's not
it's not time for that
oh
he can't if steven's not there
uh
i like
i like that it's like
two separate people now it's actually
really freaking cool
and i like it like what is eternal peace
if you're in agony over that decision
the whole time
interesting
he
huh
all right we're about to get into it
so
no
oh no
hmm
oh
all right what's happening what's going
on
[Applause]
hey
what's up sam clarks
oh he did hear it
run
oh
oh i'm liking this
oh oh yeah you guys gotta run
hey
[Laughter]
interesting
ho ho ho ho
oh that's dope
and there he is
that's dog that's a cool shot
huh
like a package deal
hmm
oh
idiots that's funny oh that's so cool
this is osiris it is osiris
yeah the gods are gonna oh moon knight a
lot
yeah yes
oh tell me she's gonna do what i think
she's about to do
tell me you are about to unleash a bunch
of different gods please
not good
why would you just
i love it
oh
oh no way
what's it gonna look like
all right this is the best episode
already
all right there's a glare on my glasses
is she gonna be the red scarab
oh
oh
oh gosh
well that's something
dude
holy crap
oh ho ho ho ho
holy crap this is awesome
this is insane i love it
oh
oh
[Laughter]
oh
no
no
yes he's got the oh
holy crap
dang
okay
that's so cool
oh
do it do it do it do it
that's really cool egyptian superhero
she's got a she's so she's the red
scarab this is a different take on it
oh
oh dang
oh
this is insane this finale is amazing
oh no
oh dang
oh snap
come on you gotta show him you gotta
show him
yo
is he not
oh
dang
that's probably the best bet
oh
he
he can't choose her now
interesting
oh come on
uh
i don't think that's mark
oh
what the hell
ah
there's a couple gold oh that's so cute
oh
all right
post credit there is one
well
you
so
so
yo
holy crap
they
absolutely
crushed it
they absolutely crushed this finale
oh
my
gosh
oh my gosh
they crushed it
they crushed the finale
oh my gosh let's tweet about it cuz holy
crap
oh my gosh
oh
that was like
wow
wow
that was
that was loki level stuff oh my gosh
they nailed it 10 out of 20 out of 10
100 out of 10. they
killed it man oh my gosh
everything was
holy crap it was all amazing
oh
wow
oh i can't believe it
oh they did it
oh
they nailed it
they nailed it
chandler thanks for super chat i i don't
know
i hope
because wow
they
uh i'm so impressed
i
i'm so impressed
uh
i i'm so impressed
holy crap that that is freaking oh my
gosh that's that's yeah jonathan what
cohen wow right i mean oh wow that
[Laughter]
yup mr anderson flawless victory like
holy crap
that was like one of the best marvel
endings ever
ever
this show crushed it this show crushed
it i enjoyed every episode thoroughly
like truly
wow
wow okay that's uh
yeah no um
congrats marvel congrats to the writers
the directors uh and frickin let's let's
just uh
let's get up for oscar isaac because
this guy deserves an oscar for this and
uh
pun intended or an emmy whatever they
give the ones to the to the shows right
because they're all they're different
but whole oh my gosh like
fantastic job by the entire cast
ethan hawk
um
yeah late i i agree with layla
laila really did kind of steal the show
huh
i mean
i always like butcher that
calamari
um
she did fantastic yes layla i mean she
was fantastic jeff i know man i think
it's a super chat like oh wow oh
i mean wow
i'm so impressed
i'm so impressed
they just they did such a good job
i'm so impressed oh my gosh
like
oh
yeah hey guys let's uh if you if you
know what happens at doctor strange
let's just not let not spoil it huh
let's not let's not be those that those
people
dude
they crushed it like
holy crap that was like one of the best
finales
oh that's fun
oh i don't know
i might i couldn't mine and chat with
yours what's that
i'll end my
just
yeah you're uh like breaking up and
discord too so yeah
i've had problems all night dang
i've had to restart my three times
that's
gosh that was a crazy finale
all right give me a second i'll be back
well uh
frick man
yeah layla did kind of uh seem like hot
girl there huh
it's funny you say that because i
thought it too so she has to be the red
scarab
she has to be the
the red scarab
i'm gonna go back and look at some
yo like midnight flying through the air
and all that stuff
sebastian batman neck what's up i know i
need season two as well like uh
gosh how how was i mean that was just
so cool uh chandler thanks for super
chat that's that's a really hard
question what was better the batman or
doctor strange too again
tonally like the tone of the move like
they're completely different
films
so it's really hard to say um
and they're paced way differently
uh
and
batman's like a grounded movie with like
you know
kind of realistic things and uh doctor
strange is like you know not it's like
witchcraft and
and uh
spells and uh
you know
sorcery and
it's jus they're like
they're very i could watch both back to
back and
probably rate them the same you know
like because
they're just so different um
i loved the batman i loved multiverse
madness you know i don't want to pick
between
[Laughter]
i think they're on par
i think they're apart excuse me
oh
i am uh
loving it mr polar bear thank you for
that super chat
i think you saw thing with some moon i
was the only room for one season this is
good towards the short films category
but he could show up in movies but
hoping that article was wrong
um
yeah basically what has been going out
um
was that
you know the reason that this was so
captivating to uh oscar isaac and ethan
hawk was that because
it was kind of a one-off thing
but you never know marvel i'm i'm
definitely guessing especially with that
post credit that we're seeing them all
again
bradley jones so is mark and steven
still moon knight and they're unaware of
jake
or how did that work well shook right no
i think that's exactly how it works i
think uh
i think mark and steven don't really
know that consciousness that conscious
still there which is uh
what just something that's interesting
all right chris is there
and now he's here
and now
i'm here
all right that was one of the best
finales come from
marvel
do you think oh for sure
that season two will be called moon
knight and the scarlet scarab similar to
captain america and winter soldier
season two [ __ ] winter show there
yeah james o'rourke thanks for that uh
super chat yeah that would be pretty
cool
jake was rolling in rolls he's the rich
one yeah anthony i i think that's true
too they kind of reverse that whereas in
the comics steven grant's supposed to be
the millionaire
yeah chris it sounds like you didn't
really like it that much
no i'm just frustrated because
nothing ever works but
well it worked for you every time but
the finale
right this is not hello i'm exhausted
life works
yeah yeah but uh no i didn't dislike it
i don't know
everyone i didn't even get to pay as
much attention as i wanted to because
i'm messing around with stupid crap not
working everyone seems to just really
love that finale
i think it was enhanced
credit scene
i think if we can get that
might have been a little bit less
for sure
i think it was
i think it would well
if if they didn't give us a post credit
and they still gave us that part
about like where he blacks out
and kind of defeats them then yes yes
then it would have been like what the
hell that would have taken away from me
right sure
right
but uh
you know the god's fighting oh man
yeah and moon knight and uh uh leila as
the red scarab was insane even though
she like really just looked like hawk
girl
she looks just like
yeah i can't really you're
you're breaking up a lot
i don't know maybe i'll just call it
uh maybe try just talking like without
the video
i wonder if that'll
ha no spiderman cameo in moonlight no
didn't think that was gonna happen
uh and yeah they're all secretly bound
to conscious still because uh
because jake lockley is there
doing his stuff
chris
yeah
seems to be better
seems to be better yeah uh you'll have
to watch that again tomorrow or whenever
and you're gonna have to let me know
because i uh
oof
i actually thought that was a pretty on
par
uh i really did i think that was uh
one of the best finales to come from
marvel um
got a super chat for you here from jake
hedge love you chris sorry your stream
died i was unimpressed ah
seems like everyone was wrong about jake
showing up in previous episode diff
language
yeah minnie shut up here um
yeah i guess i i guess i would say if i
did have one qualm with that ending i
would say uh
they
should have showed jake beating them up
yeah
um grover thank you for that super chat
yeah it was short it it should have been
longer because i feel like there could
have been uh
been some more more cool things
uh
but i just
to make a shortcut in the face you can
do a little bit more explanation maybe
there's a book
that's what i would have like
um but
yeah
yeah i um i i found it
funny that kanchi was wearing
a suit at the end
he like he liked
uh steven's take on the costume
and he's wearing a suit at the end i
think that's really funny
i got a
bunch of people in here asking
about your stream
it's definitely about internet because i
can still
like sometimes you're clear but
sometimes you're breaking up i can make
out what you're saying but
cole trump
of them what
flipping between yeah that was really
cool i really enjoyed that um
it was kind of cool how
harrah was still kind of stronger than
them and they needed that
that third personality that was
interesting
cole kind of really disappointed not
seeing the final fight
obviously jake fought but how do you
feel
do you think midnight will turn
definitely think midnight will return
and yeah that's probably my only qualm
is
i wish we would have saw it
and i i get why they did it that way but
i wish we would have saw it
for sure
it's what it is but as far as like
as far as series go
um
that was one of the better ones like
that was one of the best series so far
it was very complete yeah it it actually
does feel very complete and um
loki's still my favorite
one division still my second favorite
but moon knight is a a tough contender
for second place
moon knight's a tough contender for
second place i i really love this series
i i really did i thought it was great
and i actually really love steven the
most
[Laughter]
uh i i
stephen was great the rain thanks for
the super chat was jake slash blackout
ending to avoid probably an older ethan
hawk from having to be too physical oh
no you get stunt double stuff like that
you know they're not they're not doing
all their own stunts and stuff
it was probably just a creative choice
that they went with uh probably
specifically to set up the post-credits
scene uh king j thanks for super chat so
who created jake or is jake the actual
owner i don't think jake is the actual
owner i
i think jake might have stemmed from
kanchu
right because kanchu
is aware also this actually explains
because we were asking this question
right chris like consciou would know
right because he's sitting there
monitoring so we were sitting there like
why you know wouldn't conch you tell
them there's a third person inside of
you and now we get it right he's not
telling us they want to manipulate it
because he's manipulated and jake's in
on it too jake's the you know
the bad not bad guy but you know bad a
who's sitting there like yeah give me
this freaking power i'll use it and i'll
kill everybody right you know it's like
and i'll use it to my advantage and get
super rich from it right not because
that's exactly
yeah so i mean
i uh
yeah that's that's uh
yeah ishmael montoya thanks super chat
liked it but felt very rushed yeah i
think that's
that's pretty much what chris was saying
um should have been longer
definitely should have been longer um
i'm hoping for a midnight sun's you know
like a blade uh crossover dane whitman
all that stuff like i'm hoping that's
i'm hoping that's what we get i hope
that's when moon knight pops up again
or maybe we get moon knight and
red scarab you know
grover thanks for super chat could mark
and steven currently be trapped in
jake's head manifested an illusion of
reality similar to
in the other world uh it's possible
it is definitely possible i'm just gonna
assume
that
it's they're not like trapped i just oh
no i my whole stream my sign was turned
off eh there we go
um
i'm just gonna assume they're living
normal life and
you know
jake's the guy that comes out at night
i do wonder how like
like where were they at at the end they
were speaking spanish so i
i want to assume they were
yeah i'll have to look more into that
ending
um
i feel like they took a couple creative
liberties and just wanted to add some
spanish representation yeah maybe just
for yeah like because they have the
english and american
well right so they just wanted to give
the three different personalities three
different backgrounds almost like which
is interesting right yeah yeah one's
english one's
american from chicago and uh the other
one's spanish that's kind of cool i
actually like that
yeah so yeah grover i don't think it's
an illusion i think you know when they
sleep he comes up
uh jonathan cahoon yeah um
if you're not yeah like you don't know
who jake lockley is this
i don't know how the normal person you
know that stumbles upon this on disney
plus is gonna it's gonna think of it you
know that's a that's a good point oh i
feel like the uh explanation is at least
there you don't necessarily need to know
who he is you just realize that right i
mean they've hinted at it right when he
was dead he put his hand on him uh haro
was like and anybody else is in there i
mean we we knew there was somebody else
you know
there are other people there and moon
knight still
with stephen grant they probably still
have access to the powers and everything
they just don't know oh for sure yeah
they just yeah
um
if only they watch their channels
these people
jake heads thanks for super chat so
conscious made a deal to leave stephen
and mark but didn't agree to leave jake
so he's still in there theory 101 yeah
don't totally it's like a loophole
mr anderson conscious a
dick yep
he as it turns out khan she was even
more manipulative than we thought he was
which is kind of crazy to think about
the backup plan to the back-up line yeah
no you really did uh rana sakura hello i
just finished the
finale and wow thanks marvel hello from
france hello
uh
bonsoir
was that like
hello bonjours hello but
there's i i used to know a little bit of
french
i think that's like good evening good
night i don't know it's probably all
wrong i tried hello to france uh ethan
put
pear payout
now we know oscar isaac only signed on
for the show
do you think mooney will return from
season two or movie ah
i i'm i'm assuming he's gonna show up in
a different movie that's not his own
like blade midnight sun something like
that
luke lowe
yeah i don't think it you i don't think
a season two is out of the
out of the picture i think it could
definitely happen
uh luke i wonder if jake would have a
different costume
scarlett scarab fight from layla since
original was her father right yes
yes um
and i think they did a really good job
with that layla was a
was a great character in the show maya
um
i always forget how to pronounce her
name
i can never remember how do you i'm just
going to look right here
nope can't find it
come on credits
well we know who's not gonna be back for
season two
ethan
yeah
okay i can't
i can't find the credits
oh there it is
may
i call her maya cause layla may
callum
are we
colomboe i i can't pronounce it i don't
know anyways
uh
she she was fantastic oh she was
fantastic she's a really good job and
i'm uh i'm
i'm hoping that
we do get like
the two of them like a falcon in the
winter soldier moon knight in the red
scarab yeah ritwik that was pretty
freaking
that was pretty the giant gods fighting
part was really cool to me
um and how
oh okay mr anderson thanks
so i i tried i was going for like the
good evening thing
um
post-credits scene had moon knight logos
on the roof
daniel mudge thanks for the super chat
yeah and it also said spectre like in
the front license plate like mark
spectre so
yeah it's gonna be cool to hunt down
these easter eggs
zach lloyd thank you really enjoyed this
refreshing to get show that puts all
focus on the main character story rather
than follow the current mcu came out
crazy that actually is kind of cool
right i mean
it's actually a pretty cool thing that
it was kind of its own thing right um i
enjoyed that uh rin asakura
oh got yours just kidding
yeah uh
i'm not really sure like
there's not much to pick a part of this
hey wren thanks for coming becoming a
member super appreciate that welcome to
the gaussian fam
uh i'm not sure i can
there's not too much to pick apart about
this like it was cool it was kind of
twisted
it made you wonder what the heck was
going on a lot
it was really cool to see some gods i
thought okay here's what
here's my two cents on what i would have
done for the finale when osiris's avatar
was like dying
it was saying like they need more
avatars i thought she was going to
unleash all of the statues of the gods
i would have liked to see that i got
really excited because i thought that's
what was gonna happen
and uh
i i think we
i think we should have saw that i think
that was
that could have been the way to go
because who am i right i'm not a
director not a a writer but oh i don't
like to see it
yeah it would have been fun to see like
something he did mention osiris
mentioned something he said your gods
have felt it too
did you catch that
no when was that
right before ahmet came in and was
released
or haro came in and released on it i
think the gods showed up at the pyramid
well their avatars showed up
so i'm thinking he that's what he meant
like he was talking to the avatars about
the their gods that they served
maybe maybe maybe make sense yeah carbon
outlaw moon knight will return the
series has had some unreal positive
feedback in a way this was one done
super cool to see scarlet scarab show
yes
yes it was insanely cool and i do
believe midnight will be back hopefully
for season two because you
you never really know
um
mr wolf
on twitter marvel studios and the
official midnight account changed their
wording from series finale to
[Music]
season finale sounds like another season
oh there you go
that's something
i think they've
i do think it's hard to ignore all the
positive feedback
that that's what they look for right
that the show has gotten
and uh you know
you never really
you don't really know what could happen
in the mcu so let's keep an open mind
uh
luke another big super chat well thank
you so much
spectre and jake was the rich one or
maybe mark didn't know how much he made
as
merc since that was kind of how it was
in the comics mark makes the cast
stephen spins it invest it and jake was
an informant yeah they did switch up the
roles there um
steven's supposed to be the rich one
right uh
and jake's supposed to be the cab driver
right on the street get the information
and you know mark's the mercenary i mean
jake was driving the limo i don't know
that necessarily he was rich
i i i think it is
uh i think they switch those roles as
well but yeah you never know he said
spectre on the license plate like maybe
mark is rich and doesn't know
like well actually
on the license plate you know if you
think about it
we never really saw anything about
mark's yeah we never actually know
mark's life
right it did say spectre on the license
it said spectre on it yeah it's his car
yeah and jake is the one that drives it
around but i don't think that would work
either i don't know because jake can't
drive mark because it's the same body
right no
so it makes me wonder if like conscious
just trying to write in style
uh i don't know but i don't think if i
mean if you're a billionaire you're not
driving the limo and that's kind of what
it was a limo driver
yeah i think he i think that was
probably just for
the final rod of it all
uh khan she was the one that you know
wanted to
get the last say and like ha i'm killing
you like you're done ahmet like you're
done haro like because you know hara was
his avatar before
and i think probably for the theatrics
of it all maybe conscious was just like
put him in get in the front i'll pull
the thing down you shoot him
perhaps
jake has a driver right or mark has a
driver and someone drives him around in
a limo
uh
and you know
you gotta wonder if we'll ever get
answers for
that yeah it might not even be
irrelevant but yeah you gotta ask the
questions
oh you have to and we will speculate on
those questions uh gabriel korea
speculate on those marks speculate on
them
gabrielle thank you for that super chat
and thank you for the comment i
appreciate it love the work you've been
watching your channel for years now keep
up the good work thank you we will
definitely try
uh
for people like you
jake heads how do you think multiverse
madness affects the show zero
none whatsoever
it's not a thing
i know that i've seen the movie so i
know that uh
uh
i know it doesn't but thank you jake for
that super chat
uh daniel mudge thought all the avatars
about the suit up dude
me too that's what i would have liked
i thought layla was about to break all
the statues and it was about to go down
hippo
hippo that was such a great scene
i mean the movie
movie this year
they did
it was standing on someone you know it's
going to connect eventually was
refreshing and nice it was different the
tones were different
you know you and i have the
opportunity to kind of compare that to
what we recently saw and
we see marvel taking these risks and
going in these different directions and
that's what's cool some people some
people get to see that this weekend too
a different direction that marvel's
doing and it's not
you know the infinity saga was a pattern
you know marvel yeah yeah
yeah they copied that pattern over and
over and over again yeah and it worked
but now marvel's like well we have to
beat that
all right these risks then you got to do
that was a massive risk right exactly
and that's and and that's exactly what
we we saw yesterday and people will be
seeing this week this weekend is that
that risk again that marvel's going a
completely different direction than
anything we've ever seen
in my opinion with one division with
loki with
um chongqi which was something even
different again moon knight now and
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
it's been big risk big reward in my
opinion oh in my opinion too um
and i think that's kevin feige really i
think he knows right i really think he
knows
just uh well you have to
go ahead go ahead
no i just
i think he's the master
um i really do i just think he
knows what's gonna work
and i think he's found this groove
of like letting writers and directors
kind of make
their movie
but then obviously he gets final say and
he can twerk tweak it we need this to
happen right he tweaks it a bit it says
this this this or like no go this way
blah blah blah blah right i mean
the the sheer fact that like this is
what's cool the sheer fact that
doctor strange the multiverse of madness
was kevin feige's movie we know that
because
the director changed right and the
director left scott derrickson because
he didn't want to do it because kevin
feige had a specific thing that he
needed from the movie
and you know he got sam remy and sam
raimi really did put his
feel into it which is like a testament
that kevin feige has a way that he needs
something
but
he does give so you know a lot of
creativity to
the directors which i think works
chris murray i think yeah and that's
like
go ahead no i got super chats to
say so just
you talk first i was just saying that
really is the the genius of of marvel
has been and you always have to credit
kevin feige because it is written by
everything it's written by somebody
different
and all right from the russo brother so
taika waititi to now sam raimi's
involved scott derrickson
um
all these different people writing so
many different things and it flows
together but stands alone to create this
network of
just superiority
and it's something that nobody has
managed to do and marvel's been crushing
it since 2008 so oh i mean for real just
really and it's so like you said it's
just such a refreshing direction that
they're going down right now because it
is so different it's not like the groove
that you felt with the infiniti saga
like it said and you guys are about to
see in multiverse madness like it's so
different and it's so cool
so i can't wait all right chris moreno
thank you for that super chat
jack what's up man
how's it going haven't seen you for moon
night
how are you need to get on the call soon
yeah i did i'm way overdue for that i
apologize they made alex great actually
be around my tut uh that would have
connected the series way more yeah with
kang yeah uh what other things you think
could have been in it mid credit yeah um
see that's the thing because like
i can like i see the pattern that
marvel's doing with these shows they are
really trying to just really make it
about like the characters of the show
and not really
stray too far from that you know like we
thought falcon and winter soldier
because of magipore was going to
introduce mutants
you know or like have mutant cameo one
division was gonna introduce mephisto or
something like that like they really do
keep the focus on the characters uh i do
think kang
would have been so easy to connect with
rama tut right um
especially you know after getting loki
uh but
you know i don't have really much
complaints about this show um
i like that everything connects in the
mcu but it's kind of cool that we're
getting these one-off things but uh
yeah we'll chat we'll chat soon i'll
i'll i'll look for you on instagram
uh
hold on i know i missed a few matthew
may i love your channel i've been
watching this one division last year
about this multiverse mad thursday so
excited hey thank you so much i really
appreciate the support and hey i can't
wait for you to see it i can't wait for
everybody to see it um
i did say twerks it be quiet mr anderson
i didn't think anybody caught that
i forgot the i forgot the uh sentence i
was saying
but uh i didn't mean to say twerks
seth cook thanks for that super chat
appreciate that
rin sakura thanks for another super chat
we want jake's mustache yes we do yes we
do hey
ritwick a cosmic
fam member of the channel for five
months thank you so much i like the
finale
action was good but we need a little
explanation for the ending
who is ill and konchu
being wilson fisk in the suit in the
limo that's funny that's really funny i
actually think that konchu just kind of
like
um
liked what
steven did he's kind of like
i like this suit i'm gonna
i'm gonna take the suit on you know what
i mean that's what i kind of think but
hey thanks for uh coming to member again
uh jake was created to take
mom's physical abuse in your opinion
raiders lux that's actually uh
i kind of like that that uh
and that could be why he's so pissed off
and doesn't have any problem killing
people because
he was the one who took debut it was
just a freaking ragdoll right yeah
but i mean
i i like that idea
but isn't that mark
like isn't that the point of steven
stevens the one who gets to live the
happy free life who didn't have to deal
with all that like steven has good
memories of his mom right at a
relationship with this random person
that we don't know who we ever really
talked to because she was dead uh
so i think that was the point of stephen
was to not take that so i want to say
mark was actually the one taking it but
i do like that idea and it could
definitely be true
i think something that is really it's
not a bad thing but there are a lot of
unanswered ambiguarities of mark and and
we learned the most about stephen we
know nothing about jake yeah there's
still a lot to learn about this
character there is still a lot about
consue and all of the egyptian gods and
their relevance in the mcu moving
forward like lots lots to be explained
so
yeah yeah
and i almost feel like they need to do
like season two just to explain a lot
yeah i i think this definitely gets a
season two in my in my
i would say professional but irrelevant
opinion i i would say this needs to have
a second season yes
um okay let's differentiate something
here carbon outlaw good point seen a lot
of multiverse madness players in the
chat please don't spoil the movie ruins
it yes i agree uh but we are talking
about moon knight finale spoilers
because i see some people talking about
that well it's that discussion about the
finale guys we're talking about spoilers
uh so please please leave and i mean
that like a positive way like please i
don't want to spoil it for you craziest
part when iron man showed up at the end
i can't believe tony stark came back in
the moon at the finale of moonlight
yeah right
that's freaking funny okay hold on
there's
we want
what jake says we want chris's golden
thor one hair
i'll let you respond to that crap
what was it sorry jake hedge you know
jake of course yeah
he says we want chris's golden thor one
hair
i don't know what that means i don't
either we want chris's golden thor one
hair
yes jonathan
we are going to do miss marvel watch
parties of course jack okay so the show
is fire so let's settle the debate did
can't you ever leave i think that would
be an excellent starting point for
season two yeah no i i don't think he
left i think it was just like i think
that was the point it was a lie right it
was the manipulation like we
saw that he was doing the entire time
right he was manipulating mark because
so i bring i brought this point up again
i'll bring it again because probably
have some new viewers um
you know there's been parts where
conscious was there
where uh jake came out right um
mark was like stephen what the hell did
you do and stephen's like i didn't do
this concho was there in the cliff he
literally told the told mark like take
him to the edge he'll talk right can't
you watch the whole thing go down so he
saw another person never said a word why
because he has jake in his pocket right
so he's been manipulating mark and
steven the entire time
so no i don't think he's gone
i think he's just being uh extra
manipulative
that's that's what i think that sort of
thing luke another one thank you so much
jake is the result of army before mark
went awol here's twist there's no
bushmen
it was luckily all along
interesting
interesting but you think
that would mean jake had to like kill
himself
you know what i mean
because steven was or mark was shot at
the end and
he was about to die
so i i'm not in the sarcophagus
what
jake was in the sarcophagus there in the
afterlife yeah just no
he's talking about uh
in the origin story there was no
yeah there was no bushman
that it was uh jake i i think it was i
think there was bushmen because i don't
because that would mean jake would have
had to kill himself uh right
i mean but maybe mark
well mark says bushman right i was gonna
say maybe mark realized what he was
doing
and
actually did try to kill himself to stop
jake but
he would know about jake then so
i like where your head's at but i do
think bushmen exist
uh
micah isham okay so haro's feet are
bleeding because he put glass in them i
don't know what's real it was really
unclear to me man anyways love your
channel i appreciate that and yeah i
it's it's gonna have to be made
clear to us what that place is
because it seemed like that was you know
kind of the place in between worlds like
they you know was the underworld but
like not the underworld where they're
like frozen in sand for the rest of
their life
um
i think that's intentional i think
i think there are actually some things
that they're never going to really
explain to us
you know so
yeah do you think it's intentional um
hold on hold on hold on i know i'm
missing some super chats there we go
doom mark probably created jake to
embody his rage after getting beat by
his mom
marks the broken one stephen's the heavy
one jake's the rage i like that
and thank you so much for that super
chat dune what do you think of that
chris i i like that
and that seems
accurate
the the
to mark theory yeah like mark created
jake to embody his rage after the
beatings from his mom my question is
are there more
you know
you can always get it in the comics
there aren't in the comics there aren't
but my thought maybe is even moon not
night conscious sees hears a broken man
and manipulates that broken man and
creates jake himself maybe jake had
nothing to do with their childhood
and mark doesn't even know jake exists
because moon knight kind of conjured it
up as a backup plan this whole time he
knew what he was wanting right he said
yeah you know mark thought i wanted
layla but right
why would i want that when he doesn't
know how broken he truly is like there
could be
an infinite number of personalities and
it's like
he'll never really know right well
actually let's be clear though um
kanchu made
mark believe that he did want layla
because he was like
right which he was lying right but
conscious like oh mark thought i wanted
layla why would i want layla it's like
well you definitely led him to believe
that like even in the show he's like
might i remind you who my
second choice of an avatar may be you
know like right yeah for sure and he
even tried to get with layla oh right
yeah no i know what you meant yeah he
tried to get her as his avatar yeah
so so
conscious just a manipulative son of a
gun
so but i agree i i like that uh doom i i
would have to agree with that he's the
the rage that comes from it all but i do
also agree
um
with luke uh i think he is the army guy
you know before he went awol
uh
sorry for the cough guys
oh jake says
he just meant that they can't see
you oh
yeah
because you're not on camera
uh
yeah
jonathan which store haircut is the best
thor one in game or ragnarok i mean if
we're being honest the thor loving
thunder here looks like it's gonna be
pretty sweet
uh
brian slick thanks so much for the super
chat mark is the majority base self
steven is mark shielded jake is mark's
rage mark specter stays a good person by
manifesting parts of himself and alters
by the way you're the fourth youtuber
who is at multiverse madness who is now
audibly sick
yikes i'm not sick
chris isn't sick
and we slept in the same hotel
i don't think i'm sick i think it's just
being back
in utah it's flying big climate change
it's like really cold here
and it was not in la
uh jake hedge again the theory goes that
jake was the one that killed everyone as
a mercenary and his persona or he blamed
it on bushmen but it was really jake
yeah uh i'm gonna have to wrap my head
around that one
i can see what y'all are saying
so
they showed all three suits right before
moon night title comes up after the mid
credits
possible easter egg go back and check it
out seth cook all right
you said they show it after the post
credit
let me see i have it right here
did i read that right
right before moon knight title comes up
after mid curtis
uh
[Music]
maybe you mean before the medicare i
think you mean before the mid credits
yeah let me check that out
wait so
okay hold on
i'm not sure if that's three suits or
like
him turning in like just the
the bands going around to turn into the
the mark specter suit but maybe
that could be an easter egg
i like where your head's at i like where
your head's at for sure
yeah who knows
what do you think chris you see it
i'm trying to pull it up right now it's
before the post credits it's uh
it's right before it's like as they're
like listing like all the actors names
and stuff right before the midnight logo
plays
all right let me make sure i don't miss
any super chats
ah castic sorry i missed it does batman
show up in multiverse of madness
you know i did say it in a
in a live stream once
that it was possibility
i've continuously said every time
anybody's asked me
i wanted it to happen
i never want to see a dc marvel
crossover i do
for sure
i'm very very against it i know i'm an
odd one out i know most people aren't
but i'm very anti
i want to see dc marvel and star wars
just need to remain where they belong no
never seth cook thank you for that super
chat if i missed that
uh
i think chris moreno i think i got you
as well thanks for super chat i hope i
didn't miss any if i did i deeply
apologize
um
oh here we go
mehdi napani hello from germany
great channel oh thank you moon knife
and i was awesome maybe consecrated jake
or caused his creation by putting mark
stephen in death or life situations
going to watch multiverse madness
tonight yo
hope you enjoy it hope you enjoy it yeah
i'm i'm also wondering if like
jake is the product of consu's influence
or something like that but uh there's
also a lot of other explanations as well
like
jake is the you know the army guy
uh before mark went awol or before
stephen won awol i think or
we know we might not ever hear that
story as well
some things you don't really need to
dive that into like you know i don't i
don't need to
to hear that a wall story but i do want
to know like
the origin of jake you know what i
mean uh james
o'rourke thank you that should chat
again jake turn on bushman then switch
to mark right before bushman shot him
just a thought i like that thought
that's a good thought
it's possible
but actually but mark seems to be the
more like
um
like has more of a conscious
so
like i feel like jake would just
be like okay with it and mark's the one
that would have a problem with it but
who knows i i hope we get answers there
uh but i don't think it will
did you uh did you see it chris what do
you think i'm looking at right now i
just finally got cause i was like
pulling over the jake oh no i don't have
it
because it my recording doesn't have it
you just look at the actual you don't
have disney plus oh
i do but i was just looking
jake battinson and ant-man team up epic
serious slash laugh yeah
i i maintain
i maintain
i've already seen the movie so i can't
really i can't say so
never mind
i did say it i did say it was a
possibility they have mentioned star
wars and dc
in the mcu now well i mean they've
mentioned things from star wars in dc we
saw palpatine's lego
you know we saw the legos and no way
home uh eternals mentioned superman
i'm just saying it's possible
anything's possible the multiverse right
oh they're saying that the first thing
is the suit
right so like i think it's the bands
kind of just forming
to make
like the second suit
you know what i mean that's what i mean
that's what it looks like for sure
because you even see like the hood kind
of popping up and
maybe it's hard to tell
so i'm curious because
it says i can do super things now
i don't can you i don't even know those
are
super thanks are in your chat on your
normal videos people can tip you through
the comment section
i think that's what that was right the
same as a super chat just with that
without saying it but it's like regular
video regular videos oh apparently i
have those now
let's just show you that yeah i think
that's what those are maybe
let me see
yeah why don't we just look
anyways uh
man i
really like that finale
i thought it was really good
jonathan yeah
uh the champ never showed up they did
they did have then his name and the
phone you know when steven found mark's
phone
also why was the phone hidden
i do have unanswered questions of the
show
yeah i think that was on purpose
like they did it and knowing that
they'll never answer the questions
yeah probably they do stuff like that
all the time yeah oh you're back in
video
yeah i've been what why didn't you tell
me
oh i was just
because i'm using i'm using the
interwebs on one
over discord so
here's them to stabilize seriously
here's the golden hair
the golden hair boy is back
there's the thor hair jake
yeah i wonder if you get i wonder if she
comes in season two jonathan i uh i do
wonder about that yeah yeah
man i
i really want the midnight suns
and once you guys watch doctor strange
you're gonna go yeah the mcu can be
brutal
oh goodness me i honestly cringed at
some parts not like i was une i was i
was disturbed sometimes like i'm like
i'm like okay sam raimi okay sam remy
like
oh yeah you do have super thanks
oh it's cool i just saw it tonight
so if you're just going out like a video
where you can like like dislike and
share and stuff you can hit thanks
oh yeah that's what that yeah i don't
know essentially tipping in videos but
like not live videos right right just
normal videos well i saw other channels
had that like forever ago yeah it just
rolled out of beta it's like real now i
wonder if everybody has it or if they're
giving it check under
monetization
if i have it and wonder if you can do it
on
it's uh
monetization and then super and that's a
it's like a check mark on the top right
you can click but anyways all right just
turn it on there you go
now i can do it jake
uh chris is back up as you see lamest
part of the series was the gods
believing arthur dude okay right okay
so i said that too it's like all right
why would they do that like if only
somebody warned you i literally said i
was like they're like someone's trying
to release ahmed
it's arthur it's like if you would have
just took like like a minute like your
gods you have the ability
right just use your powers like a minute
and just go search the freaking desert
instead of just like
oh i mean concha was a douche
but like i feel like something like
that's worth looking into right i mean
like come on this all could have been
avoided
hey brian thanks for another one uh
multiverse madness continues slow march
towards mcu being an incoherent comic
flip book infinite universe equals zero
stakes and any one universe really
disappointed to see starting with rooney
peter noe home um i
i can't say too much about this because
i've seen the movie
what i can say is there were parts
in the movie that made me go
so they're leading up to this
and that's just kind of like my comic
book knowledge
um
so maybe some people won't see it but
once movies that i'll do videos on it um
and i i i actually think
that
they do add some steaks
in it what do you think chris
i like steak
i mean i love steak but
you know what i mean they added some
they they they kind of they added some
like rules and repercussions are you
talking about multiverse of madness yes
yeah and that was like exactly
on my big wish list you know i know we
were all talking about
cameos and nobody worried there's no
spoilers here
like my big wish list i mean i already
told you batman shows up
i mean it doesn't really get crazier
than that but was to get some
multiversal
ordinances some guidelines how does it
work
what are some consequences they
establish rules and they establish not
all of them because i'm sure there's a
freaking book this thick right right
right but we finally got something as
far as because multiverse is here to
stay i think the next 10 years that
feige's talking about you know we have
movies till 2032 coming
is gonna be the multiversal wars
hopefully eventually leading to secret
wars
we need to start getting like rules like
okay what happens if this happens or
what's this called what is what are the
repercussions and right they need to be
fit and they need to be stern and um we
are finally getting those introductions
and multiverse of madness is just the
biggest
pivot
in in marvel history
yeah it's
i think it's a turning point for marvel
it's so different
and i think a lot of people are gonna
really like how different it was like i
really do i really think people are
gonna go wow this was like
dark
spidey-tastic hey thank you for that
super chat appreciate that yeah i think
people are gonna
i think people are gonna
be surprised that
marvel actually went so dark
like uh like there was a lot of people
i saw like reviews today right
um from people that i saw last night
that you know we watched a movie with um
are like i'm not taking my kids to this
one
is it i mean
and it depends on how young your kids
hey the movie couple
wasn't batman your favorite part of
multiverse vandas hello wendy hello
dustin
yeah um i don't have kids i have nephews
who are too young to see movies and know
what they are anyways they're all under
two
but uh
as someone who does not like horror
me
uh
there are probably some parts
that might haunt your kids at night
i mean
i don't know if it was a combination of
the excitement on top of the wow factor
of it it wasn't really anything that
crazy that's what i yeah that's what's
comparatively two
real world movies for marvel it was
insane right yeah you're like yeah
you're in here to watch like this is not
um yeah it's not like your
family-friendly marvel movie that's not
what it is right you're used to it the
light-heartedness
there are those moments but like
let's
it made me cringe in some parts i got
uncomfortable in some parts like whoa
this is one of my um
alternate personalities my stream
decided before it gave up on me okay me
too
i don't have a name though i need a name
um i'll just go by warren and then
cosmic
oh there's the cosmic personality there
are two different people
uh
dipendra das
dipendradas kanchu planned everything to
remove all the gods so that he's the
only egyptian god with avatar in earth
to do whatever he likes that
could be it man
you never know
you really never know yeah there are
some jump scares oh definitely some jump
scares multiples of manus
uh ritwik i don't know why they released
it so early man uh on spotify i i don't
know luke another one thank you egyptian
gods are in pocket universes and can
only interact your avatars as soon as
osiris avatar died the cyrus get opened
irl time works slower
yeah so i didn't i was under the same
impression like i don't think the gods
died i think their avatars died
because like when mark died conscious
didn't die right he was released and he
didn't have an avatar so yeah i mean i'm
sure osiris and them are
are
alive as far as the gates opening yeah
that's interesting
maybe maybe osiris knew that he had to i
think osiris knew he had to open the
gate i think oh sorry because
because his avatar said are you the one
that released mark
so osiris knew or are you the one that
released konchu so osiris kind of knew
like yeah like let's
you know mark
uh let's get mark back and and stephen
back and
they knew that that was the way i am
king nelson
thanks for the super chat if sylvie
didn't kill he who remains would
multiverse of madness or nelly home even
possible the answer is no and marvel
themselves have came out and said that
just said it on the yeah
yeah yesterday i was going to say
right from the man himself
he specifically said it was beca this
all could happen
because
sylvie killed he who remains so there's
the answer coming from
kevin feige himself related
to that
strange's spell got messed up because of
it
we could have that's i think that's what
he said as well like strangest spell and
no way home
went all awry because of that
specifically like he wasn't it's not
something he's ever had to deal with
before yeah
yeah mr anderson ready to see what
raymond does remy uh
did it some good justice i i would say i
uh
i thought it was really good brie i
don't like horror either
but uh
i thought i was still really freaking
awesome
i think it's just cool to see
marvel do it
because we don't see it
and i will say you know as an avid
horror fan
yeah what's it like if you like horror
there you go right like so as an avid
horror film like fan here are the
elements that they include
the audio
when something happens right so what
creates a jump square you know something
happens and then you get like the very
piano keys like yeah exactly like those
elements are there the music is a the
one of the most important elements of
any horror movie is audio
and they do touch on that in fact
there's a very interesting scene you
guys will see towards the end that shows
exactly how deep they wanted to go with
the audio
so
sorry i was gonna say speaking of pianos
but that's all i'll say right that's
that's what i was hinting at as well
but um and then
there were like jump scares but they're
not as intense as a real horror no it's
not like it does have
these these nodes that are like
raymie knows what he's doing with horror
movies and he sprinkled little horror
sprinkles on top of this film and it is
uh
a lot of fun
it's a ton of fun to have that bleed
over into a marvel movie and it's like
wow they kind of they did this and they
pulled it off and they like we were
saying earlier they took a massive risk
and it came with a massive reward in my
opinion
same yeah no i i think they went for it
and it paid off guys we're going to end
the stream because i can't stop yeah
i i can't stop people from posting
spoilers and i don't want it yeah it's
been happening all night i will say hey
there's a moon knight g fuel coming out
that's uh not not caffeine it's a a
sparkling
water
flavored sparkling water and it is so
good
and uh highly is just getting it when it
comes out when it comes out i'll drop a
link in like my videos and stuff it's uh
it's it's really freaking good
uh
i rate multiverse madness a tinnitive
because i have to watch it again
eight out of ten
what do you think chris
i i had a sitting at an eight or nine i
really enjoyed it but like i said i do
like those [ __ ] tones i'm excited for
marvel to explore them and it did you
know one of the elements of of of
horrors is uncomfort and i was
uncomfortable yeah like in the way
possible i don't i don't when i say i
cringed and was uncomfortable i don't
mean that in a bad way i mean no yeah
it's not good horror if you aren't
uncomfortable right yeah yeah yeah
that's what that discomfort which is the
perfect way of describing some of the
scenes
was intended so i mean that's that's
what they wanted they did it so for me
that has to give it a good rate well i
will say actually yeah i might rate it
higher in all honesty you are going to
have to go live
we will either this weekend or next week
but i
i
i don't like horror but there's a part
at the end that i'm like this is awesome
and it's creepy but i loved it um my
only thing is that
i wanted a little more multiverse
jumping
and it actually could have been longer
to have more intimate parts
expanded upon that's all i'll say
that's all i'll say
uh i did a spoiler-free review the
s non i did two woman
the spoiler review is coming
on the first episode of my podcast that
airs thursday chris will be in it as
well
so look look out for that victor thank
you so much victor paul thanks for the
super chat just saw the episode holy do
i love it
that reveal was amazing yeah uh
jake was pretty freaking
was yeah that's awesome yeah future
moonlight's bright boys
and and and ladies very very much
all right we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna cut it off here because yeah the
spoilers are uh we're gonna try to avoid
this i don't want my platform to be
where everything is getting spoiled so
hey
what a finale i loved it i i truly
actually did love this finale i'm sure
it could have been longer blah blah blah
but you know what i'm like a nitpick it
i loved what i saw i thought it was
awesome moon knight and mr knight
fighting alongside each other
awesome like
steven going i can do this now look what
i can do my new you know like the
flipping awesome
loved it all
uh want more
and overall moon knight was incredible
series um
it really
really was uh shout out to mr anderson
for being an awesome mod he has a
youtube channel where he posts his own
content he'll drop the link if you guys
want to check it out of course check out
chris yep
over at cosmic culture um and of course
he you know
he works with me at the cosmic corner as
well he edits
so everything you see is is him i'm just
the voice
of the pretty face
the face and the
um
man yeah what a good week
for marvel oh gosh what a good week for
marvel uh
amazing amazing i i thought the finale
was good i'm i'm i'm giving it a 10 out
of 10. i i loved it i was
i was like the whole entire time i'm
like this is amazing like i thought it
was super cool i i thought it was super
cool uh and then the reveal of jake at
the end uh
it was really really cool so no more
super chats i am going to check just to
make sure i don't miss any but i don't
want to miss any which is why i'm saying
no more super chats
i think i got them all
deeply apologize if i didn't um
i want to know what everyone thinks of
doctor strange when they see it so
we'll do another live stream
maybe next week
so we can talk about it so
all right well this was a lot of fun i
uh
i don't know if
i don't know where we're going to be
back miss marvel
i think obi-wan's in the 27th i'll be
probably trying to do that um i think i
am doing obi-wan as well uh
disney invited me to star wars
celebration so i feel like uh i should
maybe follow what we want i mean i'm
gonna follow obi-wan regardless and i
wasn't gonna do videos but i mean we'll
see if you're already up doing it
remember
we might as well be up as well i don't
know well let's see maybe maybe we don't
have to go ask hardcore with it because
i don't think i'm gonna do the stay up
all night do the breakdown right away
after for obi-wan yeah that way we can
have some say have some sanity i was
going to say the same thing have some
sanity
yeah i can do the late night talking
it's the after this
i will say i do want to start doing live
streams weekly
i've been doing it and it's been great
chris was doing it for a while and i
truly do love interacting with everybody
uh
as i always say even if you're just
sitting watching listening reading the
chat not typing
love that you're here
people who are typing i love that you're
interacting and of course i truly
appreciate the super chats and
everything so
uh i love all this i love the community
uh you're you you all are the only
reason that chris and i are where we're
at today
so thank you all so much truly mean that
from the bottom of my heart our hearts
uh we're gonna keep trying to make good
content for y'all and hopefully get
better at it we uh believe it or not we
do try to get better at making our
content so uh we're always trying we
always you know taking notes on
ourselves and
thinking of different ideas and try to
be more entertaining hey there you go
chris
[Laughter]
um
we we try to we try to get uh
we try to be better for y'all and it's
and it's because of y'all that we that
we do try to get better so
we love you all three thousand and uh
we'll end it here but we'll be back soon
uh look out for
i probably could do multiple videos on
this because i feel like it deserves
multiple breakdown videos so uh so yeah
ritwick thank you for stopping by thank
you to all the members thank you all the
new members really appreciate that um
so we'll see you all next time
love you all three thousand
wolf